salut à tous envergure nouvelle année on
est toujours fidèle au poste meilleur
vœux à tous et toutes tout qui qui nous
écoute aujourd'hui on est reparti sur un
épisode underb c'est le numéro 4 de
mémoire et je suis avec mes grands
fidèles partenaires HUG Julien messieurs
comment allez-vous bonsoir
bonjour bonsoir pierre j'espère qu'on va
qu'on va bien comment dire aller dans
les Underdogs aujourd'hui ça va être
bien bien bien Underdogs je crois que vu
les profils on n'est pas trop mal on est
bien dans le thème on va commencer tout
de suite pour aller au fin fond des
prospect on va parler d'un pivot qui
s'appelle Joshua Morgan qui est dans une
fac qui est très connu lui il est
beaucoup moins je vais lancer HUG et
après c'est Julien qui va nous en parler
longuement HUG tu as une anecdote assez
incroyable à nous raconter à à son sujet
ou pas vraiment d'ailleurs ouais Joshua
Morgan pour vous montrer à quel point on
va très dordog ce soir si vous tapez son
prénom et son nom de famille sur Youtube
parce que vous cherchez des highlights
ou un résumé vous allez trouvé plus de
vidéos d'un garçon qui a 9 ans qui est
un prospectre pour 2032 et qui fait 5000
vues enfin sur son parcours de de jeune
joueur de 9 ans donc voilà Joshua Morgan
est un prospect apparemment moins
intéressant et MO valuable qu'un garçon
de 9 ans qui fait 4 pi je savais pas
qu'on pouvait
comp min céit 5 pi 11 bon découvrir un
garçon qui fait qui s'appelle little
Josh Joshua Morgan qui qui un podcast en
tout cas une émission sur sa vie et ça à
quel point le garçon de USC est est un
énorme
prospect direct alors en fait quand
quand tu tapes Morgan moi j'ai trouvé
jouleur de de basball sappelais Josh
Morgan mais c'est un autre sujet non
Joshua Morgan donc il joue à la FA de s
en California USC en pack 12 la pack 12
alors c'est c'est vrai que ce jeu n'est
pas trop connu donc je vais essayer de
le présenter rapidement donc en fait il
commence à la fac de Long Beach state
qui est une fac qui est dans le sud de
Los Angeles euh pour son année freshman
donc euh après de sorti d'un lycée à Los
Angeles aussi donc durant cette année
fresman contrairement à tout ce que vous
dites les gars il se fait tout de suite
connaître parce que il devient le
meilleur défenseur de la Big West la Big
West qui est une petite conférence ok
mais mais qui n'est pas négligé euh et
pendant cette année frement il est il
est je crois c'est un gros un des
meilleurs rebondeurs de la de la
division donc le meilleur défenseur et
déjà un protecteur de CERC éite donc en
2020 il change de fac alors j'ai regardé
je F 1h52 euh en en métro pour aller de
la fac de long state jusqu'à USI je
cherché sur Google il déménage ça va
vite 30 minutes en voiture et il
débarque donc à dans une fac beaucoup
plus
côté alors beaucoup plus côté parce que
donc si c'est quand
mmeor de de USC on un un petit
challengey
vasyy
to que je sois prê pour
çaz mais tu me donnes des joueurs qui
n'existe
pasaby
Jord
cure
c'était une vraie star il a été il est
quoi il est dans les 15 premiers d'une
draft non je
t'qu' vas-y
Miami m je triche pas mal pas mal et au
congouf
OK et donc il arrive dans cette fa en
2020 il est red SH il va faire que 7
matchs je crois et euh mais il commence
à se faire connaître je crois dans son
année de Junior c'est ça où il remarqué
donc par sa défense encore une fois et
l'année dernière en 2023 donc alors
peut-être que je me plante dans les dans
les si je crois que c'était l'année
dernière enfin entre l'année d'avant et
l'année dernière mais en tout cas
l'année dernière en 2023 il est élu dans
le meilleur 5 non je crois qu'il est
ouais c'est ça dans le meilleur 5
défensif de la p donc c'est pas
n'importe qui quand euh donc l'année
dernière il est leader au bloc dans la
PAACK twaves donc au contre et euh il
est 16e au niveau national au nombre non
moyenne de
bloc donc gros défonseur et il fait sa
réputation là-dessus il a 22 ans donc il
aura 22 ans aussi à la grat il est déjà
il est déjà graduate et voilà pour la
présentation
des personnellement il y a vraiment très
très peu d'informations sur lui ni sur
sa vie personnelle ni sur ses parents du
coup tu peux nous parler un petit peu du
USC parce que c'est une qui fait quand
même pas mal parler surtout ces derniers
temps c'est c'est quand même une équipe
de fils 2 surtout cette année sans
insulte oui oh quand même on con il y a
bronny James qui a eu un début difficile
cette année parce que c'est quoi c'est
son 4e ou 5e match peut-être peut-être
un peu plus mais pas beaucoup plus euh
gros problème cardiaque pendant l'été
euh il était attendu donc c'est un top
top 5 étoiles je crois ouais c'est euh
ouais et puis euh donc débarquer dans
une dans une équipe de USC avec un autre
gros prospect en au début de l'année qui
s'appelle is colier qui est blessé là
qui est
blessé dernièrement à la main qui est à
auudessus 4 à 6 semaines donc on va
beaucoup voir brony James je pense un
peu plus euh voilà c'est un programme
qui est un petit peu connu depuis
certain nombre d'années même si bon
c'est pas toujours très fun à regarder
on peut dire ça comme ça ou c'est très
peu de le dire ouais et puis il faudra
qu'on en parle notamment sur la rotation
à l'intérieur et puis donc voilà c'est
il y a quand même des gars à regarder
cette année il y a Johnson il y a colier
Bron James et donc aussi j Morgan mais
bon c'est une équipe qui tourne pas très
bien cette année beaucoup de blessures
beaucoup de de problèmes des retours des
arrivées des voilà et et puis dans les
dans la liste des fils de pour préciser
vite fait tu vois il y a Rodman c'est le
il y a DJ wman de Denis Rodman j'étais
pas que ce soit son fils donc je suis
allé vérifier donc il y a le fils de
denisman et Kobe Johnson si je ne
m'abuse peut-être que je m'abuse je
crois que c'est le frère de jyon Johnson
le l'élier fort qui est Atlanta ancien
de Duke avec un papa très caractériel
donc il y a une il y a une vraie
ambiance des papas dans le vestiaire
quoi il y a il y a un PA à faire entre
LeBron Rodman et et papa Johnson ça
rigole
bien qui débarque de Washington S et
puis comment ne pas citer quand on parle
de de
US l'éternel Boog elice qui est toujours
là toujours là à et qui ch toujours
autant ouais tout à fait magnifique
alors on va quand même parler de Joshua
Morgan un petit peu les gars exactement
alors c'est parti 2 M11 c'est un c'est
un intérieur c'est vraiment un joueur
intérieur 2 M1 mais assez fin alors il
est indiqué dans beaucoup sur beaucoup
de sites à autour de 90 kg sur le la fac
de USC il a plus de 100 kg moi je pense
qu'il est plus il doit être entre les
deux donc bon pas desmsuration
exceptionnelle impossible de trouver son
son envergure très très frustrant j'is
bien aimé savoir
donc des qualités fort longue mais pas
non plus exceptionnelle euh un
cursus comment dire sans sans éclat pas
de stat apparemment exceptionnel non
plus mais mais mais une grosse présence
dans la raquette en défense et ça on
peut pas lui enlever donc je commencer
par là euh il est encore cette année
premier premier contreur de la PAC 12
quand j'ai regardé j'espère que c'est
toujours comme ça donc en volume et en
moyenne il est alors là sa défense euh
du cercle elle est elle est élite on
peut dire hein la même avec toutes les
critiques qu'on peut dire c'est quand
même un c'est quand même une FA qui est
costaud euh c'est un joueur qui est
mobile euh qui sur les deux dernières
années moi ça m'a un petit peu frappé en
fait je je regardais pas USC pour lui
mais euh ça m'a fait ticker cette année
il est il est très euh il est déjà très
pro moi je trouve c'est-à-dire qu'il
fait
enfin il est comment dire il est mû
voilà c'est mieux comme Mo il est mû il
saute pas n'importe comment son but
c'est pas de faire un maximum de de ploc
en sautant n'importe comment il il est
plus dans le le timing dans la dans la
défense pour l'équipe et pas forcément
pour les stats je sais pas si je me fais
bien comprendre là-dessus
ouais donc voilà c'est pas un joueur
hyper mobile quand il court nord- sudud
comme dirait HUG mais euh dans la
raquette il bouge moi je trouve qu'il
bouge très bien il est vite là où il
faut euh et euh un contraint il est
assez comment dire fait il fait son taf
quoi ouais il dissuade il dissuade très
très bien c'est un très bon dissuadur il
va être moins bon s'il faut qu'il suive
à la course quoi voilà pour pour
compléter ce que tu dis euh Julien euh
là je viens de regarder de checker au
bloc pourcentage il est 9e de toute la
NC actuellement tu vois c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui est pas anod c'est pas un
joueur an et puis il a commencé l'année
quand même je crois c'était un ses
premiers match à 10 blocs contre
c'est donc voilà donc gros il est à 2,3
blocs par match effectivement c'est une
stade brute qui s'accompagne bien de ce
que tu viens dire pierre avec un bloc
pourcentage qui est assez haut dans
toute la ce qui ce qui joue un pe en sa
défaveur c'est que US dans la rotation
intérieure il y a trois gars il y a lui
il y aukou alors j'arrive pas à le dire
c'est
impossibleouou qui avait un problème au
cœur qui un prospect 5 étoiles et qui
revient et il y a kit jnny white le
numéro 33 qui a un cped neuf qui joue
aussi à l'intérieur donc il se il se
partage un petit peu les minutes et on
sent que Ben qu'on veut mettre Vincent
parce que j'ai plus envie de dire
ichouou en en vitrine pour le pour
vendre le prospect mais que Ben celui
qui fait gagner en tout cas qui essaie
de faire gagner des mats vu comment US
galère c'est Joshua Morgan le le vétéran
d'ailleurs à propos juliens tu peut-être
faire un panorama de ces stade complète
un petit peu de ce que ça donne cette
année et notamment je voudrais te
questionner sur sa alors déjà il joue
que 20 minutes par match il est que à
quat re bonds aussi par match pour un
gar de sa taille c'est quand même un peu
étonnant comment on explique ça non j'ai
pas entendu la question ah alors je te
demande euh alors c'est un jeune qui
tourne à je dis jeune 63 point point 4,5
rebond une assiste et il est à
69 pour au shoot pourquoi peu de rebond
écoute peut-être que ça lient avec ce
qu'a dit avec ce qu'a dit HUG il y a
une ça tourne beaucoup dans l'équipe au
niveau des des quatre intérieurs c'est
même parfois moi j'ai alors j'ai comment
dire suis un observateur c'est tout donc
j'ai pas de d'avis à donner sur ce que
fait le coach
US maisfed mais c'est très très
chaotique en fait comme comme rotation
en fait il y a Rodman qui est en qure et
qui est un petit peu en place et puis y
a les les quatre pivots qui tournent
Morgan
ibuku K comme tu l'as dit HUG etton page
aussi qui est capable de prendre des
minutes alors est-ce que ça vient de là
qu' y a beaucoup de il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de ça tourne beaucoup est-ce
que ça vient du fait que il y a d'autres
joueurs qui qui sont qui sont présents
notamment sur le rebond défensif j'ai
pas de j'ai pas de plus de précision à
donner mais c'est vrai que alors que c
un joueur qui était réputé pour ça pour
pour sa prise de rebond il est pas
forcément dans des moyennes élites ouais
et puis FC essaie un peu de d'accélérer
le tempo avec des gardes qui vont
essayer de récupérer le rebond alors
colar le fait peut-être pas suffisamment
c'est là qu'on attendait pour faire de
la relance style Russel wbook Bogy
elellis Coby Johnson est un très bon
défenseur donc comme tu as une défense o
tous les mecs pour le coup USC il y a
pas énormément de qualité dans le dans
le fond de jeu par contre défensivement
au rebond ils sont assez présents donc
il se fait il se fait Graille des
munitions et lui son but c'est pas de
toutes les de prendre tous les rebonds
il préfère sécuriser le rebond qu'un
coéquipier le récupère et qu'on lance
une transit donc on est sur sur un un un
rebond d'or qui va faire l'écran en
retard mais qui qui joue le collectif
plutôt que la captation individuelle
comme tu as mis sa qualité première tu
es expliquer sa qualité défensive Julien
quelque chose qui va nous intéresser
c'est sa capacité ou non à switcher
comment il bouge latéralement ce ce
jeune homme ce jeune joueur comme tu le
dis qui est plus si jeune d'ailleurs 22
ans ouais il est moi je le trouve pas du
tout ridicule quoi sur ça ça c'est quand
même un type qui a une vraie malité
défensive qui qui fait du qui fait tout
ce qu'on lui demande au niveau défensif
plutôt bien et sur switch les derniers
matchs j'ai vu il est pas du tout
ridicule euh il est capable de
d'orienter les joueurs plus petits sans
se prendre des des vents alors je dis
voilà il toujours on peut toujours
tomber sur un type qui lui fait un Coss
ça c'est sûr mais il est pas du tout
ridicule il a une bonne moi je trouve
qu'il a plutôt une bonne vitesse
latérale dans les petit dans le petit
périmètre
et il est assez agile c'est quelque
chose sur lequel j'ai peut-être pas
assez insisté mais ce grand corps assez
fin il est assez agile avec ça
il a des mouvements de rotation de du
bassin qui qui sont intéressants il est
il est pas du tout c'est pas un Tron
quoi c'est pas un Tron rigide qui est
incapable de de de bouger dans les trois
dimensions donc sur switch sur voilà ça
il pourrait être utilisé dans plein dans
plusieurs types de défense sur sur du
sur sur du switch sur du drop pourquoi
on a expliqué un petit peu sur pourquoi
du rebond c'est qualité au contre euh
une capacité aussi enfin en tout cas toi
tu vois une capacité à être assez mobile
défensivement
latéralement offensivement tu l'as dit
c'est 6 points à 70 % je crois et que
des
tirs près du cercle c'est quoi c'est
essentiellement du du dunk après passe
sur du pick and roll des choses comme ça
je crois qu'on a on a énuméré les gars
de l'équipe c'est presque que des
extérieurs qui ment le jeu qui ont le
ballon il y a il y a quatre gars qui ont
besoin du de la la balle dans les mains
euh donc lui c'est un c'est un c'est un
finisseur de bouchaîn quoi voilà un
finisseur de Bou chaîn est-ce que ça dit
c'est un finisseur quoi hein il est il
est essentiellement il est il est très
efficace hein parce qu'il y a que du
shoot à 2. 69 % c'est quand même c'est
une belle réussite quand même dans la
raquette c'est vrai que lui est
essentiellement mais je je vais aller un
peu plus loin quand même il est il est
fort dans la dans le pour faire le
screen et pour RER au Cercle attraper et
de ouis et même plus que ça il a un
petit touché euh il a un petit il a une
petite main qui avec un bon toucher près
du panier pour pour te compléter c'est
un un garçon qui quand même finit à 80 %
au panier donc il est 6% GL il a 80 % au
panier alors c'est la majorité de ses
tir vraiment sous le cercle et quand il
quand il va au panier il a un fre weight
alors le fait de faire tomber des fautes
à 71 % c'est que c'est un joueur qui a
pas beaucoup beaucoup de munition mais
quand il y va par son âge par
effectivement sa maturité et par bah le
toucher que que j écrit c'est qu'it t
l'tiqu à sa longueur il finit très bien
au panier et il fait tomber des fautes
donc voilà on va pas lui demander
énormément de choses peu importe au
niveau auquel il jouera mais tu vas tu
vas attraper le rebond tu vas courir tu
vas mettre l'écran et puis tu vas finir
au au panier et si jamais il y a une
banane tu vas récupérer un rebond
offensif et finir au poback et ça aussi
le fait bien comment on arrive à le
projeter au à l'étage supérieur en NBA
déjà est-ce que déjà est-ce que vous le
voyez en NBA et et dans quel rôle moi je
je rajoute juste un truc au niveau
offensif c'est que c'est c'est un gars à
qui on peut comment dire passer le
ballon et qui va être capable de de voir
un cut de jouer duendof plôt proprement
et qui est assez rassurant en fait je
crois que c'est comme ça qui gagne des
minutes dans dans cette rotation à 4
intérieurs là excepté Rodman
en fait on sait qu'il va pas prendre il
va pas faire n'importe quoi il va pas
être il va pas tenter des trucs de folie
mais dans ce qu'il va faire il est il
est propre voilà je vouis juste rajouté
ça sur ces sur tout ce qu' peut faire il
a une passe par match il se servir des
intérieurs ou des des arrières qui
cutent donc pour moi un joueur comme ça
qui peut être sur un temps de jeu qui
est pas forcément énorme euh qui montre
qu'il est un un défenseur vraiment
valable c'est un type qu'on va tester en
NBA pour moi donc que ce soit en fin de
second tour que ce soit sur un touet en
fait quand en préparant le l'émission je
me suis dit euh j'ai pensé à deux gars
qui sont très on peut dire qu'ils sont
très ils ont des comment dire des
qualités différentes c'est un nen Mansa
là qui est rentré alors peut-être que
vous con je sais pas si vous le
connaissez c'est l'ancien pivot de San
Diego state et qui a commencé à jouer là
avec Charlotte dernièement ouais tu vois
donc c'est un type qui était réputé pour
sa défense et qui voilà qui a une place
il va testé en NBA pendant peut-être de
3 ans et l'autre jouur Ctait
k sortie du Tha state qui a traîné je
crois qu'il est à Boston il est Boston
ou oui il à Boston voilà donc ça c'est
c'est pas forcément c'est pas le même
profil il est plus grand plus costaud
mais voilà c'est c'est je veux dire
c'est dans ça peut être dans ce style de
joueur qui va êre tester pendant 2 3 ans
pour savoir s'il peut amener sa défense
et rester sur le terrain moi j'ai un
autre nom pour toi j'ai alors je trouve
qu'il que c'est lui en moins bien c'est
Jericho Sims tu vois il me fait penser
un peu à notre ami Jericho que toi tu
connais bien maintenant ouais ouis à New
York ancien Texas qui était pas mal
mobile aussi qui était dans l'ombre tout
le temps et et qui faisait juste très
bien son travail et qui qui contrait qui
défendait très très bien c'est ces
gars-là on a tellement à l'appel de
toute façon que des fois il y en a qui
réussissent à tirer leur épingle du jeu
et puis après sinon il ils partent
jouerille als moi je suis pas hyper je
pas j'ai pas miser
surgan clairement pas euh est-ce que ça
peut fonctionner est-ce que ça peut
défendre oui c'est que voilà si tu
tombes dans un spot où il y a des
blessures comme à Charlotte et que tu
fais une bonne Summer League et que tu
lâches un touet bon bah pourquoi pas
mais on en a on en aura 10 15 lors de la
QV comme chaque QV et puis il faudra
tirer sur les PES du jeu quoi oui puis
surtout que le rôle est assez simple et
assez écrit pour lui c'est-à-dire un
rôle de RIM protecteur et RIM runnerner
quoi c'est ça VO il le fait il le fait
bien donc
messieurs je vous propose de clôturer
sur Joshua
Morgan je pense que Julien tu as été tu
as rempli ton contrat magnifiquement
c'était incroyable on va passer à on va
aller du côté de minoki parler d'un
meneur HUG au nom de Taylor collec
yes Tayler collec quel homme quel joueur
je suis trop content d'en parler ça fait
déjà 2 ans là que que je voulais parler
de de ce garçon qui joue à market on va
commencer avec un petit un petit 94
pieds avec une je vous ai préparé trce
pour la nouvelle année il il va
continuer et oui et oui et oui je suis
désolé je suis désolé alors cette
fois-ci les gars je vous demande même
pas de répondre on le laisse pour le
pour le publ je je l'ai fait en très
très courte euh trois anecdotes donc il
y en a une seule qui est vraie attention
accrochez-vous bien c'est très difficile
la première c'est que Taylor collec sa
mère elle tient un salon de coiffure qui
s'appelle collectif
euh j'ai entendu ce TR mot je l'ai
entendu attention euh la deuxième c'est
que il s'est acheté une nouvelle montre
récemment parce qu'il y en avait r cul
que tout le monde lui dise Tyler collec
il en mode
c'est relou je sais pas 1210 peut-être
et la dernière c'est que son papa est
policier voilà je suis allé très très
courte cette
année c'est à vous de c'est à vous de
voir à votre avis laquelle de ces infos
est est vrai lesquelles sont faux c'est
pas évident évident plus sérieusement
c'est un joueur tler colè qui a donc pas
une famille énormément sportive le papa
a joué dans une équipe une fac de 2e
division il a un grand frère qui joue
aussi dans une fac de 2e division c'est
pas un joueur qui est énormément côté
lorsqu'il sort de de son lycée dans le
rod Island d'ailleurs il a fait son
lycée dans le dans le rod Island dans sa
ville natale dans une ville qui
s'appelle Cumberland je trouve ça me
fait penser à concombre donc je me suis
dit j'aimerais pas vivre à concumberland
tu vois mais bon écoute il faut de tout
pour faire un monde il fait 1,91 et il
fait une première année à George Mason
fac de 18en donc mid major assez assez
moyenne en réalité il finit joueur de
l'année il finit défenseur de l'année
là-bas aussi et donc ça lui permet de
transférer assez rapidement dans un
programme de high major market qu'on ne
présente plus en terme de joueur NBA
évidemment Dway Wade évidemment Jimmy
Butler évidemment Henry enson pour
parler que des légendes
et choisi loterie he par par detro je
crois l'ami Henry enson qui avait réussi
à perdre un concours de shoot à trois
points face à Jimmy Butler al que
c'était sa spécialité ça présagé du bust
que ça allait être quand même et Tyler
colleg du coup market coaché par
l'exceptionnel Shaka Smart que j'adore
Shaka Smart qui est sûrement le seul
coach qui était complètement chauve il y
a 2 ans et qui
maintenantes j'ai envie de dire Salau
mais bon être millionnaire paraît-il que
ça aide à faire pousser des cheveux moi
j'ai pas ce ce luxe là et euh à Market
qui est une équipe compétitive qui
envoie des ces dernières années alors
qui font des des bons comment dire des
bonnes places à la marchmanes et puis
qui envoyé quelques jouur en NBA Justin
Lewis même s'il s'est fait les croiser
qu' arrive pas à démarrer et Olivier
Maxence prosperère ou Maxence Olivier
prosperère je sais jamais il a trois
prénoms c'est trop compliqué pour moi
mais qui est du côté euh où ça Dallas
non ah ouais Dallas Dallas Dallas bien
joué au max euh qui du coup fait un
début de saison enfin un début de
carrière de intéressant et euh collec
dans ce dans ce moule là c'est le meneur
de jeux gestionnaire par excellence euh
on va parler des qualités athlétique on
va parler du jeu mais c'est un mec qui
fait rien de flashy qui va pas très vite
mais qui fait tout le temps la bonne
Lect la bonne passe qui a un ratio àist
over à à plus de tris l'an dernier et
qui choot à TR points voilà ça c'est
pour le côté collectif le
côté physique les mensurations je
diamètre 80 90 kg son historiqu vasy
colleg vrai meneur de jeu un petit peu
finalement un petit peu à l'ancienne un
petit peu plus gestionnaire que scoreur
finalement qui remplit aussi un petit
peu toutes les cases parce que quand on
regarde ces chiffres je crois cette
année c'est quasiment 14 points si pas 5
rebonds donc c'est quelqu'un qui est
vraiment impliqué dans toutes les phases
de jeu ce serait quoi son son point
appelle pour un SCO NBA parce que c'est
un joueur que je trouve très bon sur
plein plein niveau et qu'est-ce qui quel
est l'endroit où il est encore le
meilleur sa qualité première en fait je
trouve ça assez difficile en fait pour
lui Ben tu as l'impression quand tu le
regardes que c'est un un joueur de 2e
division parce que pas athltique rien de
flashy et en fait quand il est sur le
terrain son équipe elle mène devant et
quand il sort il se prennent un run
c'est un joueur qui rend tout le monde
meilleur euh c'est pas des flash c'est
pas c'est pas des passes flashy à la la
mow ball c'est pas des passes flashy à
la ce que vous voulez comme comme menur
de jeu c'est juste la bonne passe le bon
intervalle la bonne lecture de jeu le
bon drive le bon tir et tout le monde
gagne donc pour moi son son point fort
pour le niveau supérieur c'est vraiment
la gestion collective le général et
bonifier complètement l'attaque et en
plus de ça par son son tir à tr point
cette année il est à 36 % l'an dernier
il est à 40 % à 3 points sur un volume
assez conséquent il peut clairement
jouer off ball donc on a un profil de
meneur qui réussit encore à exister en
NBA avec les tus Jones les TR Jones les
mont Moris et autres
ouis et puis il est c'est gars
50 36
90 avec des
volumes intéressant au shoot donc c'est
c'est pas mal quoi
ouais il il pourrait être candidat au
joueur de l'année en une c ça poserait
pas trop de problème et en plus comme
Pierre il l'a dit très très bon
rebondeur pour la taille c'est un gars
quand vous le regardez il fait toujours
l'écran en retard en fait il fait tout
très bien sur un terrain de basket et à
un moment donné dé franchises quand on
va arriver sur du second tour vont
chercher des joueurs qui font gagner des
matchs de basket alors on est plus sur
le potentiel 4 ans de fac mais tu veux
gagner un match de basket et que tu as
besoin d'avoir un mec pour dépanner tu
peux faire rentrer ce genre de gars là
il pourrait tellement sortir de la
lignée de Villanova tu vois il pourrait
être un de ces mecs là encore comme les
Archidiacono et autres qui sort de
Villanova aussi dans la Big East et qui
est un meneur de jeu qui fait gagner des
titres tu l'as dit pour pour pour le
coup on va partir tu tu as énuméré son
peut-être son principal défaut c'est son
côté justement son son manque de qualité
physique athlétique euh comment il
arrive à exister malgré ça que ce soit
en attaque et en
défense défensivement toujours très très
bien placé des mains très très actives
sur le sur le sur le ballon il lit très
bien le le rebond du ballon tu vois sur
le drible pour pour attaquer ça puissant
quand même en bas du corps on voit qu'il
y a 4 ans de fois qu'il est développé on
est à qu 90 kg je crois donc on le on
lui rentre pas dedans comme ça les pieds
bougent bien latéralement c'est pas
hyper exposif mais il bouge bien et puis
offensivement alors très orienté main
gauche c'est un gaucher mais capable
aussi de passer main droite donc
changement de direction et il a
plusieurs vitesses dans sa lenteur c'est
un un mec qui peut te surprendre par des
changements de rythme et il a aussi des
des petits go to move pour pour spin
notamment passer de la main droite
faible à la main gauche il peut spin
move il peut finir donc voilà il a il a
un un drible sécurisé et puis il passe
tellement bien tellement vite
manipulation visuelle à la passe il
envoie la balle là où le joueur doit
être et pas là où le joueur est déjà
notamment pour le Rollman on pense à
osobouo
igodaro Brendon Clark
2.0 qui se régale à ses côtés et le jeu
de mot est exceptionnel messieur je suis
désolé et donc voilà c'est c'est un gars
qui qui qui comprend le jeu qui
fluidifie tout le jeu donc tu et puis si
tu fais l'impass sur le drive en te
disant bah de toute façon il va pas
aller très vite bah il te pouope sur la
tronche et il est à 36 % au tir à 3
points donc voilà tout simplement
ouais et puis il y a les changement de
rythme puis le fait de enfin c'est ça
aussi il est est capable de de ralentir
très vite sa course de repartir il
maîtrise le rythme quand il Drive et du
coup il peut passer par des petits trous
ou s'offrir des des sles de pour finir
avec avec avec sa main gauche assez
facilement parce qu'il a il maîtrise
vraiment le
r HUG tu m'as dit que comme beaucoup de
gauchers il étit très orienté maain
gauche comment ça se traduit sur le
drive parce que comment tu trouves déjà
sa qualité de Drive sa capacité à
dribler sur un est-ce
que c'est un de ses points
forts alors ça va pas être un joueur qui
va créer énormément d'espace pour
lui-même euh c'est pas un mec qui va
partir très vite sur le départ
maintenant comme on l'a dit avec Julien
il change bien de rythme il change bien
de direction il change bien de vitesse
euh il est safe il perd là cette année
alors cette année c'est un peu moins
bien que l'an dernier mais il était l'
der 7,5 passes pour 2,5 turnover et donc
les pertes de balles qu'il va avoir
c'est plus sur des passes que sur des
que sur un drible où il met la balle sur
le pied ou il se fait intercepter donc
il est sûr c'est un joueur qui va
vraiment être très très safe après voilà
tu vas clairement l'orienter sur sa main
faible sur sa main droite sur le sur le
pick and roll tu vas essayer de lui
monter dessus euh pour pas laisser
d'espace pour tirer euh là où il va
vivre c'est que si tu euh comment dire
si tu va essayer de le traer pour lui
faire lâcher le ballon bah il transm le
ballon il fait la passe directement et
il il l'a fait correctement donc moi
c'est un G un garçon je vais pas lui
demander d'être un créateur de jeu NBA
je pas lui demandé de gérer une attaque
par contre de remonter la balle de
mettre en place un système et de gérer
une seconde unite à côté de force
scoreur athlétique qu'on qu'on a en NBA
ça il peut très très bien le faire
encore une fois dans un rôle à la tus
Jones à la trade
Jones est-ce que euh juste tu tu es
parti sur sur le rôle qu'on peut lui lui
prédire est-ce que il y a des pour les
les auditeurs qui l'ont jamais vu jouer
Tyler collec à qui vous fait penser un
petit peu dans dans le stle dans ce qui
peut dégager estce qu'il il y a des
joueurs en NBA qui qui vous dites ais il
c'est un petit peu dans la même vibe la
comparaison facile c'est d'aller sur la
sur la tête du blondiné avec la mche sur
le côté de te dire Austin Reeves euh et
Austin Reeves qui a un rôle parfait du
côté del mais Austin Wes était un un
dribbleur plus plus abouti moi vraiment
je te dirais les frères Jones euh
Archidiacono Ryan Archidiacono alors qui
est pas un un joueur qui a su
s'installer pendant très longtemps NBA
mais qui traî toujours là ce genre de
profil là Julien tu es sur le même de
vibe ou il fait penser à d'autres
joueurs gens du
jardin j'ai
luè en fait moi quand je regardais en
fait c'est unoué beaucoup beaucoup
problème
par début début
ené ouais tu vois alors c'était pas du
tout le même
joueur auss à Oregon mais ça le même
genre de problème je tuis un gars
qui capable de de peser très très
fort P trs
for
mais j'étais parti
[Musique]
jeoss puis voilà il est en
n n
Il qu'est-ce qu'il y a je dis il a signé
un deuxème contrat cet été ou ouais donc
ça veut dire que c'est un gars qui qui
fait son trou quoi alors c'est pas on
peut pas les comparer tous les deux
pareil les comparaisons c'est compliqué
mais après un gars je sais pas en fait
moi il me fait penser à des à des vieux
joueurs que je voyais quand j'étais
jeune tu
vois le mer le monur du là tu vois Joh
stcton mais c'est pas du tout le même
niveau ce que je veux dire c'est que il
est il est capable de d'enfumer des gens
avec avec son cerveau en fait quoi quand
il se déplace sur un terrain parce qu'il
sait où il faut aller il sait là où il
doit pas aller parce que il pourra pas y
aller il sait faire les bonnes passes
voilà c'est dans ce genre de de
joueur alors les comparaisons sont très
facile très
simpliste tu vois il y a un gars qui va
être qui est freshman à Kentucky et qui
lui ressemble beaucoup c'est r Shepard
et R Shepard il va drafter l' tripic
possiblement top 20
pic et on est sur ce genre de de profil
là le le si pied 3 très défensif qui
peut très bien jouer à côté d'une star
tirer à tris points et puis lorsque ta
star elle sort du du terrain et ben tu
as besoin de d'organiser un peu le jeu
de faire briller un grand intérieur tu
le fais rentrer vous avez parlé de Bor
shman il y a il y a quelques semaines en
en underdog bah Bor Sherman c'est le
même même St en beaucoup plus grand il y
a aujourd'hui un nemard qui joue du côté
d'Indiana qui est un peu plus grand que
lui mais qui sur ce profil là encore les
les me gestionnaire c'est plus c'est
plus la la norme mais ceux qui sont en
NB réussissent très bien donc après faut
juste avoir avoir un spot et et trouver
sa place et avoir une chance de le faire
mais mais je préfère parier sur ce genre
de garçon là si je dois aller sur des
des Underdogs plutôt que des des Crocker
scoreur sur les postes arrièr qui
n'auront pas la la balle en main de
toute façon ben justement la la
prochaine question est tout trouvée euh
tuas le colèg un nom appelé en juin
prochain au second tour on y croit ah
ouais totalement totalement moi je le je
je le drafte second tour et je peux même
y aller en début de second tour très
très facilement pour l'efficacité pour
le vétéran pour la défense et pour le
tir peu importe que tu le donneras en
NBA sera positif d'une façon ou d'une
autre Julien tu le drafes ou pas du coup
euh par rapport à ce que je disais tout
à l'heure oui voilà parce que non c'est
vrai que c'est c'est des profils qui
sont difficiles à à projeter en même
temps pas enfin tu as envie de voilà tu
as envie qui qui montre leur qualité au
MBA parce que il y a des choses qui sont
projetables bien sûr quoi messieurs
est-ce que nous avons fini avec notre
ami tler collec joueur àoir si vous avez
pas eu l'occasion de de le faire un une
Desgain assez incroyable qui est plus
proche de de l'expert comptable que du
joueur de basket mais superbe joueur de
basket vraiment et je ne saurais que
vous conseiller d'aller voir des match
de de de market doit en avoir sur sur
Youtube un petit peu ouais il y en a
beaucoup et en plus spécificque on en a
pas parlé mais tyor collègue vous voyez
depuis combien de temps il est sur le
terrain en fonction de ses lèvres c'est
un indicateur de de de température le
mec plus le temps passe plus ses lèvres
deviennent rouges mais rougees genre
vraiment à la fin c'est on dirait qu'il
a mis un petit rouge à lèvres Carmain et
qui part en soirée euh donc il rentre il
a les lèvres encore un peu blanches il
sort il a les lèvres rouges donc vous
pouvez voir son état de fatigue c'est
très vite scoutable pour le pour le
cardio euh je pense finir de la
meilleure des des des façons sur une
anecdote comme ça j'aime beaucoup on se
dit de toute façon à très vite euh on va
parler de plein de choses durant ce mois
de janvier il y a aussi bientôt les
bigbard qui vont sortir sur envergure.co
évidemment euh je crois qu'on est
toujours sur le dossier et puis on se
dit à très vite salut salut les gens bye
byeis bye
[Musique]
bye